in this lesson we will talk about one of
the most
famous and fundamental algorithms in
computer science
binary search we find application of
binary search
in a large number of problems in the
large variety of problems in computer
science
but here let's try to learn it in its
simplest form
and to do so we will define a problem
first
the problem is given a sorted array of
integers
a sorted array means that the elements
in the array are arranged either in
increasing order or in decreasing order
like in this array here the elements are
arranged in increasing order
let's say the name of this array is a
the size of
this array is 9 so we have index
starting
0 till 8. now given such an
array and a number or an integer x
we want to find out whether x exists in
this array or not
and if x exists in this array then we
want to find out the position at which
x exists in this array so for example
if x is 81 does 81 exist in the array
yes it even exists in the array a and
it exists at index 7.
does 25 exist in the array no 25 does
not exist
in the array does 21 exist in the array
yes 21 exists
in the array at position 3 at index 3.
now what would be the logic to find out
whether x
exists in this array or not one simplest
approach can be
that we can scan the whole array
to find out the desired number so we
start at index 0
and compare this element with x if it is
equal to x then we are done with our
search we are we have found the element
in the array
if not we go to the next element and we
keep on comparing
with the next element until either we
are finished with the array
or we find the number so let's say if we
wanted to find 63 in this array then
our search will be over when we reach
index 6
we start at index 0 and our search will
be over at index 6.
if we wanted to find out 25 our search
will be over at index 8 with the
conclusion that 25 does not exist in the
array
this approach will work irrespective of
whether the array is sorted or not
and if i have to write the code for this
it will be pretty straight forward let's
say i want to write a method search
that takes an array a its
size n and the element sorry the number
x to be searched for and the code would
be
we will run a loop starting 0 till n
minus 1
so for i starting 0 to n minus 1 if
the element at index i is equal to x
then we return i which means returning
the position
at which we have found the element x and
our search will be over
and if we cannot find any such i then we
return -1
let's say returning -1 means that we
could not find the element
we could not find x in the array a
now with this algorithm if we are lucky
we will find
x at first position itself so in the
best case we will make only one
comparison and
we will we will be able to find the
result
in the worst case when x would not even
be
present in the array we will scan the
whole array we will make
n comparisons with all the elements in
the array and then we will be able to
give back a result that hey x does not
exist in the array
so the time taken in the worst case is
definitely proportional to the
input size of the array sorry size of
the array
or in other words we say that this would
be big o of
n in terms of time complexity it's
always good to analyze the running time
of an algorithm in the worst case
and find out the upper bound of the time
taken
now in this case the time taken grows as
a linear function of
n so we also call this search linear
search
and once again if we are using linear
search we are not using any property
like the array sorted or not whether
that is sorted or not this will work
now let us try to improve this algorithm
using the extra property of the array
that it is sorted and i will make some
space here first
let us say we want to find out whether
13
number 13 exists in the array
a so x is 13
and we want to find out whether x exists
in the array a
now we will use a different approach
this time instead of
instead of comparing x with the first
element as we do in the case of linear
search
we will compare it with the middle
element in the array
now the size of this array is nine so
the middle element will be at
index four now there can be three cases
here
case one can be that x is equal to
the middle element if x is equal to the
middle element we have already found x
in the array
case 2 can be when x
is less than the middle element and case
3 can be
that x is greater than the middle
element
clearly if x is equal to the middle
element our search is over
because we have found x in the array if
x is less than the middle element
then because the array is sorted it lies
before the middle element
and we can discard the middle elements
middle element and all the elements
after middle element
similarly if x is greater than the
middle element
it lies after the middle element so we
can discard
all the elements before the middle
element and of course the middle element
as well
so in case 2 and 3 we discard
half the elements from our search space
and reduce our search space
so in this example when x is 13
initially our search space
is the whole array x can exist anywhere
in the array
now we compare it with the middle
element which is 36
now x is less than 36 so it exists it
should exist somewhere
before 36 so we discard all the elements
after 36 and 36 as well
so now the problem gets redefined we
need to search
x only between index 0 to
3. so how do we keep track of the search
space
we keep track of the search space using
two indices start
and end so initially the start would be
0 and end would be
the last element in the array in this
case the index 8
because initially the whole array is our
search space
and we calculate mid as start plus
end upon 2. now once we find out our
reduced search space
we adjust start and end accordingly so
in this case
after comparing 13 with 36 and
discarding half of the array our
end now becomes index three
which is nothing that but one less than
the middle element
now we again find out the middle element
in this reduced
search space so here the middle element
will be 3 plus 0 by 2
if we take only the integral part 3 plus
0 by 2 would be 1.5 and if we take the
integral part the middle element would
be
index 1. once again is it equal to x
no 6 is not equal to 13 is x less than
the middle element is it case 2
no it is not x is greater than the
middle element
so this time we discard the middle
element and all the elements towards its
left and this time we shift start to
mark our new search space
now the new search space is starting at
index 2 and
ending at index 3. now what is the
middle element 3 plus 2 is 5
5 by 2 is 2.5 and the integral part is
2 so this is our middle element
so x is now equal to middle element we
have found our element
so we are done with our search
this kind of search where we reduce the
search space into half
at each comparison is called binary
search
once again we are able to reduce the
search space by 2
or in other words we are able to reduce
the search space into half
only because the array is sorted array
being sorted is a precondition for
binary search
okay so let us now write code for this
algorithm
i will write a method binary search
that will take as argument and array a
its size n and a number x to be searched
for
in the array and i will initialize two
variables
start to 0 and end
to n minus 1 so start and end
define our search space initially the
whole array is the search space
now i will write a condition here while
start is less than or equal to n and
i'll come back to why
i'm writing this condition so while this
is true
start is less than or equal to n we will
find out the middle
index of the search space as
start plus end upon 2 and now we will
write
three cases if the middle element is
equal to x
then our search is over we return
the index stored in the variable mid and
exit from the function if x is
less than the middle element then we
need to discard
all the elements having index greater
than or equal to mid
so our end of the search space now
becomes
mid minus 1 and
in the third condition which will be x
greater than the middle element
which will be the default condition
after these two if and
else if we need to discard all the
elements with index
less than or equal to mid so our start
becomes
mid plus one
and if we exit this while loop without
returning anything
then we return -1 which will mean that
we were not able to find the element
x in the array
now why this while statement here with a
condition
start less than or equal to end what we
are basically doing
in our algorithm is that we are reducing
our search space
recursively by adjusting the start and
the end pointer
now there must be an exit condition to
our recursion
the exit condition can be either we find
the element in the array so we return
and exit
or we exhaust the whole search space
when start is equal to end
or start is less than uh end then we
still have such space
when start is equal to end then our
search space has only
one element so when this condition
becomes false we have exhausted our
search space we need to
exit the loop and we need to return -1
to tell that the element the number x
does not exist in the array
now once again in this case in the best
case we can find
the element x in just one comparison
when the first middle element itself
will be
the element x in the worst case we will
keep reducing the search space
till the search space becomes one
element so from n we reduce to n by two
and from n by two we reduce to n by four
and we go on
till our search space becomes one now
how many step does it take
let's do some math here let's say it
takes
k steps to reduce n to one
by keep by dividing by two at each step
so n by two upon k will be equal to 1
and if you solve this then k will be
equal to log of n
the base will be 2. so in the worst case
binary search will take log n
comparisons and so the time taken also
in the worst case is proportional to log
n or in other words
uh it is big o of log n in terms of time
complexity
and big o of log n is a lot lot more
efficient than
uh o n algorithm so this was binary
search we will take more problems
on binary search in the coming lessons
thanks for watching
in the previous lesson we learned about
binary search as an efficient algorithm
to
find or search element in a sorted data
in a sorted collection in this lesson in
some real code we will see how to
implement binary search
and we will also see what are the common
errors that happen
while implementing binary search but
before that
a quick recap let's say we have a sorted
array of integers
something like this the elements are
arranged in increasing
order and the size of the array is 6 so
the indices are from 0 to 5.
now let's say we want to find out
whether the number 10 exists in this
array or not programmatically
using binary search now in binary search
what we do
is we take two pointers two variables
that point to
that initially point to the first and
the last element in the array
we may call them start and end pointers
we may call this variable start and end
or we may also call this
low and high to mark the lower index and
the higher index
now start and end these two variables at
any stage in our algorithm
give us the range in which the element
can
the element may exist so this at the
start of the algorithm the element may
exist anywhere within the array so
that's why start and end are
pointing to the first and the last
element now we calculate
middle point using the equation
middle is equal to low plus high upon 2
or start plus
end upon 2 and we take only the integral
part
so here 5 plus 0 upon 2 would be 2.5 and
taking the integral part will give us
this index 2 as the middle index so we
are searching for 10
number 10 and initially we are in a
state where
lower index is 0 higher index is 5
and so mid index is 2
now we see that the element at the
middle index is the desired element
if it is the desired element our search
is over so
the element at the middle index is 6 is
6 equal to 10
no it is not now we see whether this
element
is greater than the target element or
less than the target element
now 6 is less than the target element
which is 10
so we discard 6 and all the elements
before 6
because they are also less than 10 and
we shift start to
point at index three so we go to
this state lower index three higher
index five and now we search for
our number in this part of the array
only now if we calculate mid then mid
is equal to 4 5 plus 3 upon 2
is it equal to the target element 10 yes
it is equal to so we have found found
our element on our search is over
we found 10 at index 4. okay what if we
were
we were searching for the number 9 in
the array if we were searching for 9
till this step it would have been the
same thing
now at this step the middle element is
10 we compare it with 9
and i'll also modify it here now 10 is
greater than 9
so definitely 9 can only exist before
10. we need to discard
this part of the array and we need to go
to a state where
our search space is defined by low equal
3 and high equal to 3.
now 3 is both low and high and mid
element of this range would also be
3 only now this mid element is also not
equal to
our desired number 9 is not equal to 8.
now once we have only one element in our
search space and we have still not found
our desired element our search is over
and we could not find the element
let us now implement binary search and i
will write a c program now
okay so what i will do here is i will
first write a method
named binary search that will take an
integer array its size let's say the
size of the array is
n and let's say the element to be
searched for
is x and this method returns
an integer which will be the l index of
x
if it is found in the array now we will
declare two variables
low and high and initialize them
to 0 and n minus 1 respectively
low and high at at any point
give us the segment within which x may
lie
ok so now we declare another variable
mid that is calculated
as low plus high upon 2
now we compare x to the element at index
mid
and there can be three conditions here
first condition will be when
x is equal to the middle element
the element at index mid and in this
case our search is over we will simply
return the index mid
and when we return from a method we exit
it
now the second case can be when x is
less than
a mid now because x is less than the
middle element it will lie before mid
so now we redefine our segment by
shifting
end to shifting the higher index
to mid minus 1
and this should be else f okay and the
third and the last condition which will
be the default condition here
when x will be greater than the middle
element in this case we will redefine
the segment by
adjusting the start or the lower index
and lower index will be equal to mid
plus 1. now we need to keep
repeating these three steps again and
again
so how do we do that so we will
definitely need a loop
so we will put a while loop here now
when do we stop
executing these steps we stop either
when we find the element so
either when we return or when we are
done looking at all the elements so i
will put a condition here
while low is less than or equal to high
when low becomes greater than high then
the segment defined by low and high
will not be a valid segment when low is
equal to high then
we will have only one element in the
segment now if we
exit this while loop without returning
anything then we can say that the
element x is not in the array let's say
we return -1
to say that x does not exist in the
array okay so this is the binary search
method
and and let us now write the main method
and try to use this function
in the main method i will first declare
and initialize an array let's say the
name of the array is a
and we fill some elements into this
array in sorted order remember the array
being sorted
is a precondition for binary search okay
so this is an
array of size 8. now let's ask the user
to enter a number
that we will search in the array so we
will write a printf statement here
and now let us in take input of this
number
now i will call binary search to search
whether
this number exists in the array a or not
size of the array is 8 and we want to
find out x
okay i will rather name this as x
because
we have been naming the target element
as x
throughout okay so now if
index which is the return from the
method binary search
is not equal to -1 then we have found
the element x
in a so at this stage we will print
something like
number x is at index
index index is the variable name as well
else we will
print that we could not find x in the
array
let us now run this program and see what
happens
so we are asked to enter a number let's
say we want to search for number
15 in the array okay so this says that
number 15 is at index 6
and let us now try to search a number
that does not exist in the array
let's say we want to search for 18
and the output is number 18 not found
there are some common errors that happen
in binary research implementation
resetting these indexes low and high
should be done correctly and we should
always be careful about this
exit condition from the loop one more
common error is
when people do not put this bracket here
now what will happen here is that the
precedence
of division operator is more
so high by 2 will be calculated first
and then it will be added to low so this
bracket is important we need to
put this bracket here and some people
also calculate
mid as instead of calculating it as low
plus high upon 2
we also calculate it sometimes as low
plus
high minus low upon 2 and this is a
better way of doing it
because sometimes low plus high can
exceed
the maximum value that an integer can
store
so like a 32-bit integer a 32-bit signed
integer can store
maximum value of 2 to the power 31. now
if both low and high are pretty high
then high plus low will exceed 2 to the
power 31
and cause issues in our program
execution
it should be pretty evident that this
expression evaluates to high plus low
upon 2 only
the only difference is that we are
avoiding overflow by not
calculating high plus low in this
expression
okay so this was binary search
implementation and
in this implementation we have used loop
so we have
written an iterative implementation you
can write binary search using recursion
also i would recommend that you try that
on your own
in the coming lessons we will see more
variations of binary search and
its application in other scenarios so
thanks for watching
in our previous lesson we learned about
binary search
and we also implemented binary search
but we implemented an
iterative version of binary search in
which we used
loop to write our program now in this
lesson
we will write binary search using
recursion let us first quickly
write an iterative version of binary
search
so i will write a method binary search
that will take as argument
assorted array a the size of the array n
and an element x that is to be searched
for
then we initialize two variables low and
high
load to zero and high to n minus one
and we say that while low is less than
or equal to high
calculate middle index as low plus high
upon 2.
it's a better practice to calculate made
as
low plus high minus low upon 2 which is
the same thing except that
we are not calculating low plus high
sometimes low
and high individually are within the
limit of
within the range of an integer variable
but high plus low
overflows the range or limit of an
integer variable
now there are three conditions if x is
equal to the middle element we have
found
x in the array so our search is over we
return the index
mid and exit else if x is less than the
mid element
we adjust high to mid minus 1
to to say that we discard anything which
is
on or after mid because x is less than
the middle element and the array is
sorted else if x
is greater than a mid which should be
implicit here for the third condition
as the third condition in this case we
set low as mid plus one
and if we come out of this while loop
without finding anything
we will return minus one to say that x
does not exist
in the array a what we are essentially
doing here is that if we have an array
in which elements are in increasing
order then we first compare
x with the middle element and if x is
equal to the middle element it's fine
if x is less than the middle element it
must exist
before this element in this highlighted
section
and if x is greater it must exist after
the middle element in this particular
highlighted section
and we keep on repeating this process in
the new segment
until either we find x or we cannot
divide the search space
any further at low equal high our search
space becomes
or rather reduces to size one reduces to
only one element
after that we cannot divide it any
further binary search is a typical
example of
a divide and conquer algorithm in which
at each step we are dividing the problem
into half
let us now write recursive
implementation
so once again i will write a method
binary search
that will take a sorted array a and this
time the arguments will change a little
we will take two arguments
low and high to mark the segment of the
array in which
x may lie at any stage x is the element
to be searched for
and the logic would be something like
once again we will calculate
the mid index and then we will have
three conditions
if we find x that's good we return the
index at which we have found it
if x is less than a mid we call binary
search
recursively on the range low
and i'm running short of space here so
i'll create some space here
and we will run uh the we will call
binary search recursively for
index low to mid minus 1 so x is now
to be searched between index low to mid
minus one
else if x is greater than a mid which
will be the third condition
anyway we will return binary circle
from mid plus one to high so we make a
recursive call to
search x from index mid plus 1 till high
when we write recursion we should always
look for a base case
a base condition where we would stop our
recursion
in this case we will stop our recursion
if we find the element so this case will
return and exit
and we will not make any further
recursive call but what if we do not
find the element
what we what if we do not find x in the
array
we have another base condition for that
where we need to exit
if low is greater than high then we do
not have a valid segment
in the array and in this case we can say
that
we have exhausted our search space so we
return -1 to say that
x does not exist in the array i'm short
of space here so i'm writing these two
statements in the same line
so these two are our base conditions
that would cause the recursion to stop
or exit and this condition low greater
than highs
the same condition which we are checking
here to stop the loop
let us now quickly simulate this
recursion using an example
let's say we have this array a a sorted
array of size 9
and we want to search for number 63 in
this array
so we make a call to the function binary
search
and i will write bs here as shortcut for
binary search
okay we pass to the function the array a
and
lower index should be 0 and higher index
should be 8 to say that initially
the number can exist anywhere in the
array from index 0 to 8
and the number to be searched for is 63.
now we go inside the function
is low greater than high no so we go
ahead and calculate mid
mid would be calculated as 4 the element
at index made index 4 is 36
and 63 is greater than 36 so we come to
this else condition the third condition
and we make a recursive call to search
for 63 within range
mid plus 1 would be 5 to 8.
now once again for this function low
greater than high is not true
so we calculate mid mid would be 6
if we take only the integral part and
element
at index 6 is 63
so we have found this element we will
return mid
so we return 6 here and this method
finishes and this method also returns 6
to its caller maybe the main method
let us now say that we want to search
for number 25
so we make this call to binary search
from the main method
now once again we calculate the mid now
element at index
436 is greater than 25
so we make a recursive call to search
for 25 from
index 0 to 3 okay now is low greater
than high is 0 greater than 3 no so we
go ahead and calculate mid
mid would be 1 element at index 1 is 6
25 is greater than 6 so we make a
recursive call to search for 25 between
indices two and three
now mid would be two and this time we
will make a recursive call to
find 25 in the range three to three it's
still a valid range
low is not greater than high mid would
be three
and now 25 is greater than 21 so
we make a recursive call using the third
condition to
mid plus one would be four and lower
high would be three still
and this time low is greater than high
so we come to this condition
where this method simply returns minus 1
and finishes
now this method also returns minus 1 and
this gets propagated all the way up
and finally this method returns minus 1
to its caller the main method
while writing recursion we must be very
careful
about the base conditions like we have
these two base conditions here
if we do not get our base conditions
right our
recursion may go on endlessly causing
the program's memory to overflow
and causing it to crash the time
complexity of this algorithm
is big of login the time taken is
proportional to login and this comes
from the fact that if we keep dividing
the size of the array by 2 at each step
then it will take us log n steps
to reach array size equal to 1. now one
obvious question which one is better the
recursive implementation or recursive
implementation or an
iterative implementation well anything
that we can write using recursion we can
write it using iteration and anything we
can write using iteration we can write
it using
recursion iteration is a slightly more
performant it's better in performance
because we do not have to store all
these states of
all these functions the extra functions
in the memory
but writing recursion may sometimes be
very intuitive and easy to write
for most practical reasons you may
choose
any of these according to your comfort
so that's not an issue
okay so this was recursive
implementation of binary research for
you
thanks for watching
in the previous lesson we saw the
implementation of binary search
in its basic form we solved a
problem in which if we have a sorted
array of integers
something like this and if we want to
find out whether a number
exists in this array or not so let's say
we want to find out whether number 10
exists in this array or not then our
algorithm returns
us that 10 exists at index 3
and if we want to search for a number
that does not exist
in the array then our algorithm returns
us
that the number that you are looking for
does not exist in the array so if we
want to search for 11 in this array then
our algorithm says that 11
does not exist in the array okay so now
i will modify this array now this array
is still sorted
but the only difference is that we have
three occurrences of number 10
in the array now let's say we want to
search for the number 10
using binary search then what will be
the index of 10 that we return
we could return 2 also index 2 also we
could return index 3 also
or we could return index 4 also the
normal binary search implementation that
we saw previously
exits as soon as it finds out any
occurrence of a number in the
array so there is no guarantee that we
will find the first occurrence or the
last occurrence
now in this lesson we will see two
different variations of binary search
one variation will always give us the
first occurrence of
a number in the array and another
variation will always give us
the last occurrence of the number that
we are searching for in the array
okay so let us first write the basic
implementation that we had written
previously
i'll quickly write a method binary
search that takes three arguments
array a its size n and the element to be
searched for
x and we will initialize two variables
low and high
to zero and n minus one to mark the
segment of the array in which
x is probable to lie and while low is
less than or equal to high
we calculate the middle index as low
plus high upon 2
and then we compare x with the middle
element and if x is
equal to the middle element then we have
found x and our search is over we
exit from the method by returning this
index mid
so we are exiting as soon as we found as
soon as we find
any occurrence of x not necessarily the
first or the last occurrence
but any occurrence if x is less than the
mid element we adjust
high to mid minus 1
to say that x will now x is now probable
to lie
before the mid element and the third and
default condition is when x is greater
than the mid element so in this case
we are just low to mid plus one
and if we come out of this while loop
without finding x
then we return minus one to say that we
could not find
x in the array okay let us see a
simulation of this for this
particular example simulation of this
algorithm for this particular example
i will draw three columns here low high
and mid and let's say the number to be
searched for is
10 so x is 10. size of the array is six
so initially low is zero
sorry size of there is seven so
initially low is zero high is six
now we have started to execute this
while loop we calculate
mid as low plus high upon two so mid
would be three
let's also try column a mid okay this
looks better
now a3 is ten so is x equal to a mid
yes it is so we return three we return
three
and we will say that game over because
we have found 10 in the array and we
return immediately
we do not care that there is another 10
at index 2.
now if we want to find out if we wanted
to find out the first occurrence of 10
in the array
we should not have said game over we
should have said that okay
i have found 110 at index 3 let me go
and see towards the left if there is
another 10 at any lower index
and if it is there i will return that
one
so i will modify this algorithm slightly
here at the beginning
let's say we take a variable result
and initialize it to minus one
i'll come back to why i'm initializing
it to minus 1 and i'm short of space
here so i'm writing two statements in
the same line with a comma
now when the condition is that x is
equal to the middle element
instead of returning and exiting the
execution of the function
we modify result to x
sorry we modify result to mid the index
at which x lies
and we adjust high to mid minus one
once again i'm short of space here so
i'm writing two statements in the same
line
so these two statements will execute for
this condition if x is equal to the
middle element
now what do i really mean here what i
mean is that if
we found x in the array then we have
stored the index in the variable result
at which we found x
and then we modify our segment we do not
stop our search and we modify our search
space
by adjusting high to mid minus one so we
keep on searching for x
before this mid element so if we see the
simulation now
then we do not stop here we make high as
2 and continue our search now mid would
be 1
a mid would be 4 i will also write the
value of result at any stage so far our
result is
so far we have found 10 at index 3
so our result is 3 now for this case low
0 high 2 and mid 1 we will go to the
condition
this one when x is greater than the
middle element so low becomes mid plus 1
so low becomes 2
high is already 2 now mid would also be
2
amid would be 10 now we come to this
condition
we again came to x equal to the middle
element of the segment
so we now modify result to the new index
at which we have found
x so result will be now 2 and high
becomes mid minus 1 which will be 1
low is 2. now this condition low less
than or equal to high fails
so we exit while loop here ok there
should be one more modification to my
code
i will return result here okay so we are
saying here that
found 10 at index 2 so this way we have
found the first occurrence of the
element 10 in the array
we are returning result here once we
complete the while loop and we are not
returning result
inside the loop result is initially -1
so
if we do not find any x it is never
modified and we return -1 to say that we
could not find
x in the array and if we find any x in
the array and i'll
put braces here to mark that these two
statements execute for this if condition
we stored that index in this variable
kind of saying that so far this is the
left most result that i have
and then we go on searching towards the
left by left i mean
towards the lower indexes so we modify
high to mid minus 1
if we find another x then this x is left
of the previous
index so we discard the previous
result and modify our result okay so
this is binary search to find out the
occurrence of first element in the array
if we want to find out the last
occurrence in the array
then there will be only a slight
modification to this code
when we find x we do not stop the search
like we are doing here
and we go on searching towards the right
towards the higher indices by modifying
our wind
window or the segment or the search
space by adjusting low
to mid plus one by adjusting lower index
to mid plus one
and this is the only change that we need
to do to find out last occurrence in the
array
okay so let us quickly see simulation
for this implementation also
so once again we start with low 0 high 6
and we also start with result minus 1
minus 1 means that we have not found
x in the array so far now mid would be 3
and the mid element would be 10. we are
executing the while loop here
now we come to this condition x is equal
to a mid
so first we modify our result we found
an
x at index 3 and then we
modify low to mid plus one which would
be four
so earlier our window was the whole
array now our window search space is
this
and we already have information about
the right most
10 that has occurred so far okay so now
mid would be 5
a mid would be 18 now we go to this
condition x is less than a mid
so now high becomes mid minus 1 so we
have this range
our window our search space is now this
and so far we have found 110 at index
three
now mid would be five plus four upon two
and if we take only integral part then
it is four
a mid would be ten so once again we can
to
come to the condition when x is equal to
image so we modify
result to the new index four
and we modify low to mid plus one so low
becomes five
high becomes five so far the highest
index of ten that we have found is four
and our search window is now
only index five so mid would also be
5 and a mid would be 18
now 18 is greater than 10 so we will
again once again go to this particular
condition
so low is still 5 and
high becomes four now now this is not a
valid search space this is not a valid
segment low
less than or equal to high condition
fails so we will exit the loop
exit the while loop and our game is over
we result
we return whatever we have in the result
so we will kind of say that found 10
at index 4. so
this is binary search to find out the
last occurrence of an element
in the array in a sorted array
the time complexity of this algorithm is
big o
of log n or in other words we can say
that the time taken is kind of
proportional to log of n
in the coming lessons we will see more
variations of binary search
we will see other scenarios in which
binary search
is applied so thanks for watching
in this lesson we will solve a very
famous programming interview question
and the question is that given a sorted
list of
integers we want to find out
how many times a particular element
occurs in this list
so let's say we are given a list in the
form of an
array here we have an array of size 12
and the elements are in increasing order
now
how many times does number five occur in
this array
five occurs five times and how many
times does number two occur in this
array
two does not occur in the array so we
will be given
any such sorted array a and a number
x and we have to find out how many times
this number
x exists in this array a
now we want to solve this problem
programmatically so let us think through
the different approaches that we may
want to
follow the simplest approach is that we
can scan the whole
array and count the occurrences of x
in the array so if i have to write a
function find count
that will take as argument array a its
size
n and the element x to be searched for
the element x for which we want to find
out the count so the logic would be
pretty straightforward we will take a
variable
initially let's say the name of the
variable is count and we initialize
it to 0 and then we run a loop
starting 0 till n minus 1 and if
a i or the element at index i is equal
to
the element x we increment count so
count becomes count plus 1 and finally
when we count come out of this loop
we return count so we are performing a
linear search where we are scanning the
whole
array to search for element x
we could optimize this algorithm a
little bit something like this
because the array is sorted once we
reach a stage
when a i becomes greater than x
we can stop counting but still in the
worst case
this loop will run n times
when all the elements in the array are
same then this
loop will run n times so in the worst
case this algorithm
the running time of this algorithm is
proportional to n in other words
the time complexity is big o of n
this is a very simple solution for this
problem
and if you give this solution in a
programming interview
the interviewer would be like i do not
like this give me something better
so how do we find out a better solution
whenever in a problem we are given a
sorted data or a sorted collection we
should
try to think about applying one very
famous algorithm that makes the best use
of
this property that the data is sorted
and this algorithm is binary search
so can we make use of binary search in
this problem
one thing that we can do is that using
binary search
we can find out any occurrence of the
number x
in the array so let's say in this
example we want to find out
count of number five so we let's say we
find out
using binary search and big o of log n
time
that number five exists at index six
now because the array is sorted all
occurrences of five will be
adjacent to this so we can go towards
higher indices starting this index
and look for all the 5 and then we can
go towards the lower indices
and look for all occurrences of 5 but
once again if the whole
array is number five only all elements
being same
still is a sorted array then we will
scan
all the elements we will access all the
elements in the array
and eventually the time complexity will
be
we go of n only the time taken will be
proportional to n only in the worst case
so using binary search kind of does not
give us
much advantage if we use binary search
in its basic form
big go of n because to perform binary
search we will take big o
of log n time and then to find out all
the
adjacent occurrences of x we will take
big o of n
in the worst case so for higher values
of n
log n is negligible in comparison to n
so this is eventually big o of n
we are not writing writing pseudo code
for this approach
we leave that as an exercise for you
with these two approaches we are still
big go of n in the worst case so what do
we do
well if you remember from our previous
lessons
on binary search we can write a binary
search to find out the first occurrence
of an element in an array
and similarly we can write a variation
of binary search
to find out the last occurrence of an
element in an array
and this forms the basis of our third
approach
and i'll clear some of this and make
some space
okay so we can use one variant of binary
search to find out
the first occurrence of an element in
the array and we can use another
variation of binary search to find out
the last occurrence
and if we know the last and the first
index at which
the element occurs then we also know the
count of it in the array
so once again we will write a method
find count
that will take an array a its size n and
the element
x and let's say we find the first
occurrence of the element
in the array using a method find first
which is a variation of binary search
and we will use another method called to
another variant of binary search that
will give us the last occurrence of the
element in the array
then we can return count as last index
minus
first index plus 1 and
i'm not handling the case here when the
element is not present in the array
let's say
we will handle it well in our actual
implementation
okay so the first method call if we are
using binary search will work in
we go of login and the second method
call to find out
the last occurrence will also work in
big o of login
so overall the time complexity to find
out
the count of an element in the array
would be big o of log
n and that's really great
we have described how to find out the
first
or last occurrence of an element in a
sorted array
using binary search we had written
pseudo code
for the algorithm in our previous lesson
and there is a link to
the previous lesson in the description
of this lesson
but let us now go and write some real
code
to solve this problem i will write a c
program let us first write a simple
normal binary search
and then we will modify it to find the
first or the last occurrence let's say
we have a method binary search that
gives me
the index of element x in the array in
binary search we first defined two
indices
low and high two variables low and high
initially set to zero and n minus one
respectively and then we find the mid
element
as low plus the mid index as low plus
high upon 2
and then we compare the middle element
with
the number x and if we
if middle element is equal to x we have
found our element
so we simply return the index mid else
if x is less than the middle element
because the array is sorted
remember array being sorted is a
precondition of binary search
we set high as mid minus 1 kind of
saying that search
in the segment left to the middle
element
and if x is greater than the middle
element we are just
low to mid plus 1
and we keep repeating this process again
and again
till the time we have a valid segment
and a valid segment
is still the time low is less than or
equal to high
and if we come out of this loop without
finding anything then we return -1 to
say that
x does not exist in the array problem
with this implementation is that as soon
as we find
any x we return so there is no guarantee
that we will find the first index or the
last index
if there are duplicates in the
duplicates of x in the array
so what we do is we will what we will do
is we will
modify the algorithm slightly we will
have another variable initialize it to
minus 1
and now when we find x then
we do not return and exit we update the
result variable
to kind of say that okay this is the
lowest index of
x so far and then we continue the search
so if we want to find out the first
occurrence then we adjust
high to mid minus one so we update
result and go on searching towards lower
indices lower segment
and finally if when we come out of this
loop then we return result so if we do
not find anything
any occurrence of x we simply return
minus 1 because this was initialized to
minus 1.
now this implementation will give us the
first occurrence of x in the array
and what if we wanted the last
occurrence the only difference would be
that
we will go on searching towards right or
higher indices so we will
say that low is equal to mid plus 1 now
go on searching towards the higher
indices
now i want two different functions for
finding out the first or the last
occurrence
but if you see there is difference in
only one line
in these two implementations so what
i'll do is i'll use the same function to
retrieve both first and the last index
based upon another argument a flag
so let's say we have a flag as a boolean
parameter
search first if it is true we want to
search for the first occurrence and if
it is false
then we want to search for the last
occurrence so if we want to search for
the first occurrence
then we want to in the case when
a mid is equal to x we want to adjust
high to mid minus 1
else we want to adjust low to mid plus
1.
okay let us now write the main method
what i'll do is i'll first
initialize an array
and i'll ask the user to input a number
x now we want to find out the count of x
so we will first make a call to binary
search method to find out the first
index
in the uh array so we will pass the
array a
the number of elements in the array
which is 12 and we may also
calculate the number of elements using
this particular
equation size of a upon size of
a 0 size of the number of bytes in the
whole array
upon the number of bytes in each integer
in each
element and we want to search for x and
we will pass
true because in our method declaration
if this
flag is passed as true then we search
for the first index
else we search for the last index now if
first index is returned
as minus 1 then the element is not in
the array
so no need to find the last index we can
simply print that
the count is zero else we find out
the last index and this time we make
the call to the same function binary
search
with the only difference that this time
we will pass the flag as
false so we will say that hey give me
the last index
and we will print count as last index
minus
first index plus one so this is our code
this is our method binary search and we
have made call to binary search twice
to find out the first and the last index
and we decide first or last index using
this flag
let us now run this code and see what
happens let's say we want to find out
the count of number three
then this gives us that three occurs
twice which is right
let's now try number five and count of
five is five
and let's give x is equal to 2 2 is not
present in the array so the count will
be 0.
so this is an optimized algorithm to
find out count of an element in a sorted
array
this is a classic implementation of
binary search
in the coming lessons we will see more
problems on binary search
so thanks for watching
in this lesson we will solve another
programming interview question
and the question is that we are given a
sorted array
that has been rotated so let's say we
have
been given a sorted array with these
elements
the size of the array is 6 so we have
indices
from 0 to 5 and let's say we want to
rotate this array anti-clockwise rotate
this array towards the right
so each element will shift by
1 towards the right except the last
element which
will shift to the first position in the
array
and the resulting array would be this
and this is rotated once and if we
rotate the array twice
the resulting array would be this and
this is
of course rotated twice and such
an array is often also called circularly
sorted array
so we have been given such a circularly
sorted
array and there is one more condition
there are no duplicates in the array
all the elements in the array are
distinct so given such an array we have
to find out how many times the array has
been
rotated so how do we solve this problem
one thing that should be pretty evident
is that if we know the first element or
the minimum element
of the sorted sequence in the array
then we know how many times the array
has been rotated and when we say
the number of times the array has been
rotated for this problem we mean
rotation in anti-clockwise direction or
rotation towards
right the number of rotations of the
array would be
the number of elements before the
smallest element or the minimum element
in the array
so in this case there is only one
element before 2 which is the minimum
so clearly this array is rotated once
here we have two elements before the
minimum element so this is rotated twice
in fact if we see then the number of
rotations is equal to the index of the
minimum element
so our problem is basically finding out
the minimum element in the array the
index of the minimum element in the
array
and we are done we know that how many
times the array has been rotated
so how do we find out the index of the
minimum element
the simplest approach would be to scan
the whole array
perform what we also call linear search
and the pseudo code will be something
like we will have two variables
one to store the minimum element and
another to store the minimum index
let's say initially the first element is
the minimum element and then we run a
loop
from 1 till n minus 1 where n is the
size of the array
and if the element at ith index is less
than the minimum
we update the minimum and the minimum
index
and finally when we come out of this
loop we will have the index of the
minimum element clearly
the running time of this algorithm would
be big
o of n the running time will be
proportional to n now this will give us
the correct answer this is a correct
solution but
in this solution we did not make use of
the property of the array that it is
circularly sorted
can we use this property of the array
and improve this algorithm
improve the time complexity of this
algorithm well
let us see now we will make use of the
property that the array is circularly
sorted
and we will use a variation a
modification of
binary search algorithm to solve this
problem
now what do we do in a normal binary
search algorithm
let's say we have a sorted array like
this we first find out the middle
element in the index in the array and
then we see whether this is the element
we are looking for or not if it is not
the element that we are looking for
we either go searching towards the left
or we go searching towards the right
based upon whether the element that we
are looking for is greater than or less
than the middle element
so at each step we divide the problem
into searching something in half the
array
at each step we discard half of the
elements
we discard half of the search space and
we keep on going until we find the
element
now in a circularly sorted list like
this
our problem is to find out the first
element of the sorted sequence
this particular element is kind of the
pivot
or the junction in the circularly sorted
array
so now we will use a variation of binary
search to find out this pivot element
which is also the minimum element in the
array
what we essentially do in a binary
search is
we define a search space a segment
within
which our desired element is probable to
lie
by two variables low and high
the lower index and the higher index and
at each step
we either find an element or we reduce
the search space by half by discarding
half of the elements in the segment and
creating a new segment
and now we look at the new segment we
kind of divide the problem
at each step into half now in this
problem for each segment we will look at
couple of things
there can be a case when the lower
the element at lower index is less than
or equal to the element at higher index
now this will be possible only if the
segment is already sorted
if the segment is already sorted the
minimum element in the segment
and that's what we are finding out the
minimum element
in the array and if we can find out the
minimum element in the segment that will
be the minimum element in the array as
well
so we will return simply return the
index low
because the array is already sorted so
the element at lower index is
the minimum now if the segment is not
sorted
we calculate the middle index and now we
try to see if our middle index
is the pivot or not now how do we find
out the pivot
if you see there is a special property
of the pivot or the minimum element in
the array
if we see the next and the previous
elements
of the pivot element in a circular
manner
so if it is the last element the next
element would be the first element
then for the pivot element both next and
previous element in the array
are greater than it like here 18
and 5 are both greater than 2. no other
element in the array will have this
property
except the pivot element let's define
this property as
pivot property so here we calculate
next as mid plus 1
modulo n modulo n because if
mid is the last index in the array we
need to go to the first element so
module operation does that
and previous would be mid minus 1
modulo n and we will also add n here so
that mid minus 1
does not become a negative number so our
case 2 is
that a mid is less than or equal to
a next and it's also less than or equal
to
less than or equal to the previous
element
in the circular array in the circularly
sorted array
if this is the case once again we have
the
pivot or the minimum element in the
array so we will return
the index made so far in these two cases
we have found our element straight off
and we have not felt the need to divide
the array
divide the search space search segment
now if the middle element is not the
pivot then can we use a property
where we can say that we can discard the
right half or we can discard the left
half
and we can go to one of the halves to
search for the pivot element
well yes it is possible to do so if the
middle element the element at
mid index is less than or equal to the
highest helmet at high index high
then the segment starting the mid index
and extending right towards
till the high index this whole segment
is sorted
and the pivot cannot exist in the right
segment so in this case
we will say that we need to search for
the pivot in the left half
so we will adjust high to mid minus
1 and case 4 would be when the mid
element is greater than or equal to
the element at lowest index now in this
case it is not possible that
the pivot is in the left so we will go
and search in the right so we will
adjust
low to mid plus one
so we keep reducing our segments at each
step
and try to find out the answer now let
us simulate this
approach this algorithm for this
particular example so for this example
case one obviously is not true initially
so we find out the middle index
now the pivot property is not true for
the middle index
so we look at case three when we look at
case three we basically are looking
whether this whole part of the sequence
is sorted or not including 18
and the whole elements towards the right
so 18 is not
less than or equal to eight now we look
for case
4 and when we look for case 4 we mean to
check whether this complete sequence
is sorted or not well this is sorted in
fact if the
array is not sorted then one of these
two sequences
will always be sorted you can pick up
some of examples some examples and
try to see and this is what forms the
basis of
our divide and conquer approach this is
what frames the forms the basis
upon which we discard half of the
elements
so now we need to adjust low to mid plus
one
so we have discarded these elements from
our search space our
new search spaces starting at two
now this array is sorted case one is
true for this segment
sorry this segment is sorted so we
simply return the index of 2 which is
0 1 2 3 and 4 so we return 4 here
and our search is over now we have found
the
pivot element so we know that the array
is rotated
four times equal to the index of the
pivot element
of things about this algorithm this
algorithm will work only if
there are no duplicates in the array and
that was our initial condition also in
the problem
if there are duplicates this reduction
of such space into half
is not possible and let us now write
code for this algorithm and see whether
it works or not
so i will write a method find rotation
count
that will give me how many times a
circularly
sorted array a is rotated n is the
number of elements in the array
so we first define low and high and then
while our search space is valid we first
see whether the
segment is already sorted if it is
sorted we return the lower index
so this is our case 1 else we calculate
mid
as low plus higher 0.2 and then we also
calculate the next and previous of mid
and if mid satisfies the pivot property
we return mid
else if the middle element is less than
or equal to the higher element
then we discard the right half and we
adjust higher index 2 mid minus 1 else
if
a mid is greater than or equal to a low
then we discard the first half the left
half if the array is not sorted one of
these two conditions
will always be true and only one of
these conditions
will be true not the both of them let's
say if we are not able to return
anything if we are not able to return
anything within the while loop
then we return -1 it will be -1 will be
written only for an invalid scenario
when
maybe the array is not circularly sorted
its properties are not true
now in the main method i have
initialized an array of size 11
and i have called this function find
rotation count and i am trying to print
the count
let us see what happens if i run the
program
this says that the array is rotated six
times
which seems to be correct let's now
modify this array
let's run this for a test case when
the elements are already sorted okay
this also looks fine
so we are good now i have used four
cases to solve this problem
uh there are a couple of different other
implementation approaches as well the
underlying idea would be the same to use
binary search but
we can implement using some different
conditions
i encourage you to try them out on your
own or quickly google search for
code snippets so this was one
interesting problem using
solve using binary search in the coming
lessons we will see more such
interesting problems
thanks for watching
in this lesson we will solve yet another
very famous
programming interview question and the
question is that we are given
a circularly sorted array which means
that
a sorted array has been rotated and in
the previous lesson we had also
solved a problem where we wanted to find
out the number of rotations
in a circularly sorted array this is an
example of a circularly sorted array
the first element in the sorted sequence
is at index 4
and then we go towards the right
and then after the last element we go to
the first element
so this is the start of the sorted
sequence and this is the
end of the sorted sequence each element
in the sorted sequence has been shifted
four positions ahead the array is
rotated four times in anti-clockwise
direction or towards the right
now given such an array we have to find
out whether a number
x exists in this array or not
so how do we solve this problem the
simplest approach would be to perform
a linear search where we scan the whole
array
to look for x but in this approach we
will not
make use of the property of the array
that it is circularly sorted
and the time complexity for this
approach would be big o
of n where n is the
number of elements in the array so what
else can we do
whenever we have a sorted data and we
have to search for something
we should always think about binary
search ads
as one of the possible approaches binary
search as we know executes
in big o of log n at most we make log n
comparisons
to find out our element in the array and
big o of log n
is the best time complexity to have for
a solution
so let's see if we can apply binary
search in some form
to solve this problem let us pick up
this
circularly sorted array the example that
we have in the left
and now we will use a variation of
binary search
to find out an element x in the array
like we do in the normal binary search
we will first
define two indices low and high
initially to the first
and the last element in the array
respectively and then we find out the
mid element as low plus high upon 2 the
mid index
so far the logic is the same now the
first case
would be that the element at mid index
a mid is equal to x as we do in a normal
binary search
we will compare the middle element with
the number that we are looking for
x and if this is equal to x
our search is over we will return mid
telling that x exists at index mid
if a mid is not equal to x then if the
array was
a normal sorted array then we would have
either go into the left half or the
right half
depending upon whether x is greater than
or less than
the middle element but we cannot apply
this straightforward logic to
discard one of the halves in this case
but there is a property that we can
exploit and discard half of the elements
if you see then the elements in the
array are always increasing
except only at this particular point
which is the junction point
or the pivot point where we have the
first element or the minimum element in
the sorted sequence
now if we pick any segment or any
sub array then if it does not contain
this
uh pivot point if it does not contain
these two elements which form the
boundary
the break point then all the elements in
this
segment will be sorted and if the
segment contains these two elements
that form the breaking point then the
segment
will not be sorted now the mid element
divides the segment into two halves
and this break point or the pivot point
will lie only in one of these halves
so at least one of these halves will
always be sorted
we will make use of this property and we
will discard half of the array at
half of the search space at each
iteration of the binary search
so our case 2 will be
if a mid is less than or equal to a high
basically we are looking at this
particular part of the array we include
the mid element and
look for the segment extending till the
highest element
if this condition is true then this
whole segment is sorted
in this example this segment is not
sorted but if
this segment was sorted the right
segment was sorted
then there would be two conditions let's
say these conditions are 2a
and b we know that x is not equal to a
mid
but if x is greater than a made and
x is less than or equal to a high
then it definitely lies in this sorted
half
so we are just low to mid plus one to
say that
go ahead and search in the right half
else if it is not so we will have a
condition when we will say
go go search in the left half in the
unsorted half
okay this will be the case when the
right half of the array is sorted
case 3 would be when a
low or the first element in the sequence
is less than or equal to the middle
element
less than or equal to a mid now in this
case we are looking whether this
particular segment starting the
low index all the way till mid index is
sorted or not
now once again we will have two
condition two conditions
when we know that this half is sorted it
is very easy to verify whether
x is probable to lie within this segment
or not within this
sub segment or not here if x is greater
than
or equal to a low and x is less than
a mid x cannot be equal to
the mid element because then we would
not reach the case 3
then x is probable to lie in the left
half for this condition
so in this condition we will adjust
height to mid minus one
else we will search in the unsorted half
by adjusting load to mid plus one
so this is our divide and conquer
strategy for binary search
let us now write code for this and see
if it works
i will write a function circular array
search that will
search for a number x in an
array of size n and it will return the
index of x
if it is found in the array so like we
do in a normal binary search we will
first define two
variables low to zero and high to n
minus one
and while low is less than or equal to
high
while our search space is valid
while our segment is valid a valid
segment segment will have at least one
element when low will be equal to high
we calculate the mid index as low plus
high upon
2 now if x is
equal to the middle element then we have
found x
we return the index mid else
we need to decide whether to go in the
left half or the right half
whether to go searching towards the
higher indices or the lower indices
and we do so by first finding out
which part of the array is which part of
the
search space is sorted if a mid
is less than or equal to a high the
element at index high
then the right half is sorted
if the right half is sorted then we can
easily check whether x is probable to
lie within this sorted half or not
so if x is greater than the middle
element and x is less than or equal to
the element at index high we go
searching to the right sorted half by
adjusting
low to mid plus one
else we know that the element is not in
the right half so it is definitely in
the left half so we will adjust
high to mid minus 1 to go to the left
half
now right half is sorted for sure we
know that but left half
it could either be sorted or unsorted it
doesn't matter
for some special case when the segment
itself is sorted it
the left half could also be sorted but
irrespective of that using these two
conditions we are discarding one of the
halves and we are going to
one of the we are choosing one of the
sub segments
okay so now if the right half is not
sorted
then the left half definitely will be
sorted so either we write this condition
a mid greater than or equal to a low
or maybe i should write a low less than
or equal to a mid
as we had written previously so this is
case three even if we do not write this
condition and simply write an else
we are fine because this will be true
anyway
at this point so now the left half is
sorted so we can see whether
our x is probable to lie in left half
now
if if x is between a low and a mid less
than or equal to
greater than or equal to a lo and less
than a mid
then it's probable to lie in this half
so we will adjust high to mid minus one
else if x is not probable to lie in the
left half
then we go searching towards the right
by adjusting
low to mid plus one
and finally if we come out of this while
loop without finding
x without returning anything we return
-1 to say that we could not find
x in the array let us now write the main
method
we will first initialize an array a and
this is the same
array the elements are the same as we
have used
in our examples throughout now let's ask
the user to input
a number x from the console
and now we call the method to search for
x the size of the array is eight so we
pass eight as the second argument
now if this method returns minus one we
will say that we could not find the
element in the array
the number in the array and if it is not
minus one we print the index
so this is our c program
and now let us run this and see what
happens
let's search for the number 8 in the
array
and this seems to be correct the element
8 is at
index 6 let's run this again and search
for number 12 in the array
and this also is correct
and this seems to be working for other
cases as well
and let's modify this array let's say we
want to pick up an
array in which the elements are already
sorted let's pick up eight elements
again
let's search for element four in this
array
okay this is also fine so we seem to be
good for all test cases
well actually no we are not good for all
test cases
if we have an array with duplicates
like this this array is still circularly
sorted
this is the first element in the sorted
sequence zero but if we have duplicates
in the circularly sorted array it will
not be possible to
decide whether left half is sorted or
right half is sorted
using the conditions above that we have
used using these
this condition so the array has to be
strictly increasing
in a circular manner and all the
elements need to be distinct
if we run this let's say we want to
search for number zero
then this says 0 not found in the array
which is not correct
if there are duplicates we cannot do any
better than big o of n
we will have to perform linear search
only if the elements are distinct we can
perform
binary search okay so this was searching
an element
in a circularly sorted array with no
duplicates
using binary search thanks for watching